welcome back to st louis
you've been gone for so long how does it
feel to be back and playing in this
event yeah i have been really missing
the jazz tournaments here since the
pandemic and
for me personally this is
a great opportunity to
get back to over the bulges yeah first
of all i'm very happy to be back i'm
very thrilled i'm just glad to be here
saint louis really is my second home
it's the center of chess in america and
every chess player wants to be in the
city well it's good to play in st louis
again it's been forever for me i think
the last time i played mustard in the
sink field cup two years ago
um because i played the online events
but
actually playing in this building it's
been it's been two years so it's good to
be back it's been a long time and it's
definitely
great to be back for
face-to-face
real chess these tournaments are always
extremely enjoyable apart from
potentially the results in them but
playing here is always fun
players are treated
unbelievably well and
you know the club is
by this point i've spent enough time at
the club both as a player and as a
commentator that it feels like home i
think for me the difference is that
really since i haven't played in so long
i'm just trying to see how i do get get
the feel for it um because you really
don't know what to expect i mean we've
all played a lot online but there have
been very few over the board tournaments
and i'm just looking forward to seeing
how i do
yeah it's uh been quite a while since
i've been here i think the last time was
back in november of 2019.
i was pretty crazy and definitely
excited to be back and ready to play
some good chess
yeah i'm very happy to be back i'm
feeling very lucky that i was able to
actually travel and be part
it's always nice to play on the porches
but with this current situation in the
world i think it's just you know
really a privilege course is very nice
to play in saint louis we're all nice
for me it's like his world chess center
i mean he has every very strong
tournaments and all strong players
played here well i couldn't be more
thrilled to be back in st louis it's now
been over two years since i've been here
and it's certainly my favorite place to
play chess it's my home away from home i
still remember last time i was here some
lady asked me in the street for
directions and i knew where to send her
so yeah and to make my grand chester
debut is also fantastic
i've never been a great rapid and blitz
player compared to my classical strength
but i have done work on that and
over the course of the pandemic trying
to get better
of course i don't know if it will pay
off or not we will see but i'm looking
forward to it